so let me guess you started working on
your first POI flowers and you're
finding this right here is happening why
it's cuz you don't have conscious
control over when you are spinning the
POI and in this lesson I will teach you
how to gain it this friends is your
introduction to beat
control Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm sharing
with you a lesson on how to gain control
of something that I like to call beat
control but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyroar
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission okay so
first up I have to Define what do I mean
by beat control well a lot of us when
we're first starting off say if we're
doing our butterflies our three beat
weaves Etc we're unconsciously training
our hand to keep on spinning the poy at
a constant rate so when time comes that
we want to switch over into doing our
ins spin or antipin spin flowers we find
that we're still completing those beats
at a regular rate and the problem is is
that when we want to go to our anti-spin
and ins spin flowers we now need to be
in conscious control of when we complete
a beat with the poy and the good news is
this is a skill that can be learned but
it takes a little bit of work so I'm
going to give you three exercises in the
course of this video that are going to
help you get there two of which directly
tie into doing POI flowers so hopefully
this will help some of you out there
that are struggling with this all right
so our first exercise here is going to
involve unlearning some of the habits
that we have already learned in terms of
keeping the same amount of energy going
into the PO and we're going to be using
pendulums to do it all right so we're
going to start this off with an easy one
namely I just want you to work on going
back and forth between pendulums and
spinning the POI I want you to add only
enough energy into this to get the POI
to spin over your hand once and then go
back to doing pendulums going back and
forth like so really what this teaches
you is how to begin adding energy to the
POI and then taking it back away notice
that as I come around and do one
pendulum two pendulum take it over one
pendulum two pendulum take it over I can
then go back the other way by adding one
more pendulum boom pendulum pendulum
over pendulum pendulum over like so and
after this it's time to start playing
around with some flowers all right so
our second exercise here is going to be
familiar to anybody who has ever learned
inpin flowers from me namely I'm going
to start you off with extensions and
have you add petals to them here's how
this exercise starts you want to just
let your hand and arm go around in a
really big circle around your shoulder
and then you're going to let out the poy
to become a long extension of your hand
and arm note I'm only completing one
beat with the poy as I do this I'm
trying to keep the poy more or less
Frozen in relationship to my hand
there's no point yet where the POI goes
around my hand it stays straight out
from it so we're going to go ahead and
add one of those beats and we're going
to do it up top and what that just means
is you're going to pause your hand for a
moment at the very very top of the
extension and let the Poise circle
around it once no more we do 10 reps of
this and then we go back to doing a full
extension and then we pause over on the
side and once again allow the PO to do a
complete circle around the hand like so
resume going back to the extension and
then pause to let the PO go around the
hand only on the
bottom otherwise we're still doing that
big extension around we're just pausing
it when we hit that point right next to
our
hips finally after we return to an
extension one last time we pause our
hand over on the other side of our body
to again get just one beat out of it
before we get back to our extensions
like so so at this point you now have
four different points around you where
you can pause the PO and that means you
can either do petals on either side of
the body or you can do petals top and
bottom or if you want to you can pause
your hand in each of those four spots
and come up with a four petal inpin
flower it's really important though know
that you can both add petals and take
them away whenever you want to have the
capacity to do both whenever you so
choose so for our third exercise here
we're going to be playing around with a
variation on something I refer to as a
linear isolation it's one of my favorite
tools for teaching people anti-spin
flowers and also very crucially it's
really good for teaching people how to
add and remove beats in anti-spin all
right so this exercise starts by
spinning the PO clockwise over on your
left hand side and then doing a little
stall down your Center Line your hand is
going to continue off to your right hand
side boom and it's going to make the PO
continue to spin around clockwise now
you're going to do a stall up your
Center Line and as you do so your hand
is going to sneak underneath the poy
head back over to your left side so we
dip down on the right we pop up towards
the left dip down going right pop up
going left now this is really important
you want to do this in such a way that
you're going directly back and forth
between the two sides you don't want to
pause on either side and add beats
because well that's the whole point of
the exercise is to try and get in
control of how many beats we're
performing here now the best way I know
to do this is to tell people to either
think that your mission here is to tag
four points that is you're thinking tag
left tag down tag right tag up tag left
down right up as you're going back and
forth or if this is easier for you you
can think of it as being a three beat
move thinking left center right left
center right and just forget the part on
top because this right here is not
actually a beat of the poy it sneaks in
in between two of the Beats so again we
think left center right left center
right and that should do the job for us
now comes the fun part we're going to
start taking out some of these popups
and drop downs we're going to start by
taking out the drop and so when I get
over to my left hand side here I'm
instead going to hook my index finger
under underneath the tether of the POI
and fling it over my hand my hand and
POI kind of race over to my right hand
side basically trying to arrive at this
point at the same time from here I still
do the pop up going back to the left but
now I'm hooking going over so I hook pop
hook pop hook pop so if we had basically
two petals when we started out now we've
only got a single petal
like so and now our next move is to take
away the one petal that remains and we
do that as we're going from the right
side to the left side by just dragging
the Po underneath our hand and then
flicking it over drag flick drag flick
drag flick now we have zero petals cool
so let's add one back in namely when I
go back to the left hand side let's
bring back down the drop down our Center
Line and then we drag back drop drag
drop drag drop drag drop drag and we can
get back to the pattern that we started
with by adding back in that pop up and
take out the drag so Al together this
full pattern is we do Drop Pop Drop pop
and then we do fling pop fling pop fling
drag fling drag drop drag drop drag Drop
Pop Drop Pop the idea here is that we're
learning how to be consciously in
control of when we spin the poy and when
we do not in that anti-spin space each
and every one of those patterns can be
expanded out into a different anti-spin
flower or nearly anti-spin flower the
net result of this once you have worked
through all of these different exercises
with both hands is that now rather than
trying to work your way through Flowers
by keeping the POI spinning constantly
you'll be fully in control of when you
do create beats with the POI and when
you don't and that leads to those
beautiful flowers that you are used to
seeing your idols on YouTube and
Instagram put together pretty cool and
hey if you're looking to level up on
your PO techniques you're in luck
because that is the topic of the flow
Circle for the month of July the flow
circle is an exclusive lesson that's
available only to my supporters on
patreon that gets delivered to your
inbox this month the theme is exercises
that will help you get down these
fundamental po skills everything from
drilling those Tic Tacs and different
planer orientations to developing hand
Independence so you can perform a zero
point with one hand and not the other a
crucial skill for getting down
transitions sign up now over at
patreon.com Factor poy the first lesson
is already up did you get anything out
of this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all rock thank you so
much and if you all out there watching
are not currently supporters but you'd
like to become supporters you can do
that by heading on over to to my patreon
at
patreon.com drexfactor poy there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission of bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world check that out please and thank
you and if you'd like a lesson
specifically for beginners on how to get
down their first inpin flower I did a
video on that very recently how to learn
your inpin flowers in 30 minutes or less
I'm going to go ahead and link to that
down in the description as well as up
here on screen thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with the new
video real soon take care now peace